everyone this is kevin from the chess
website com2 they're going to be
continuing our coverage of the 2014
blitz of world championships today we're
gonna be looking at a match from the
last round so they played 21 rounds both
Thursday and Friday combined why it's
going to be played by Magnus Carlsen
going into this final round Magnus
Carlsen actually has a full point lead
on second place if he can just draw or
win this match he will be the blitz
champion which is crazy considering he
just won the rapid championship two days
ago and he won the world champion for
four normal chess or normal time chess
just a few months prior in at the end of
2013 against Vichy and on so this would
be unprecedented to win all three in
less than a year
so hit that's what he's going to be
going for again if he can get a draw
very very quickly that would be fine for
him unfortunately he runs into a very
tough opponent onsen core bomb actually
the 2013 European blitz chess champion
so very very strong Challenger across
the board from him good news from Magnus
Carlsen as he is playing the white
pieces well go ahead and get into it
starts with pawn to d4 pawn c4 and then
we see from onsen we see the semi Slav
defense a very strong defense from black
but kind of a waiting defense to see
what his opponent's going to do we see
just a natural progression of
development moves from both sides of the
board nothing too crazy both sides
recognizing the magnitude of this game
in particular and so both sides just
developing pieces as normal if we get
into it's after this this is the 12th
move let's try to determine what both
sides are gonna be pulling right now
white is gonna be looking to attack this
isolated pawn here on d5 also wants to
try to find something for his
LightSquared bishop his dark square
bishop is fine here on b2 magnus carlsen
can really control this long diagonal
right here
but his life square bishop sort of
awkwardly placed it's defending this
night here on
three but it can't come to see for the
natural square can't come to be five you
know you may not even want to play this
d3 because you may actually want to get
your rook behind here on d1 he may also
try to just exchange off some pieces
he'll definitely want to get his rook
over here to see one at some point get
that very active wants to bring his rook
over here to a d1 and then just see how
play continues but a lot of his efforts
gonna be focused on this square here on
d5 right away now black on the other
hand Anton is really going to be trying
to first complete his development he
first needs to get his LightSquared
Bishop out hasn't moved yet get his
Queen involved into the game he has a
few options as far as this pawn here on
d5 he can try to hold on to it although
he is gonna have to be playing somewhat
defensive he can get his riffs behind it
if he wants to try to hold on to it or
if not he could give up that material
and hopefully for that pawn he could get
some competition as far as an attack on
the Queen side or maybe the the King
side so so either way definitely both
sides have some options that they can do
going into the middle game we now see
Bishop here to g4 again getting that
LightSquared Bishop involved Knight
capturing here on e5 nice little
exchange Bishop coming here taking here
on a g4 and then the the knight
recapturing here and I love this move
from Magnus Carlsen recognizing that his
LightSquared bishop it was going to be
difficult to get involved into the
action you know if he had a couple hours
in the match it would be very easy for
him to get a very active LightSquared
bishop in blitz you only get three
minutes for your entire game you get two
minutes incremental per move so you do
get a little bit of time at it each time
you play something but you don't want to
spend a lot of your time just trying to
get one of your pieces developed so you
usually have somewhat of a different
approach in different situations if it's
blitz or normal even a rapid you have a
little bit more time so Manglish Causton
recognizing some of his weakness and
immediately gets that off the board and
now he doesn't have to worry about
getting his LightSquared bishop involved
into the game so now we see pawn here to
h3 kicking back that Knights
knight back here to e2 did have a few
options you know he could have easily
brought his rook over here to c1 he
could have brought his rook over here to
d1 I think both of those make a lot of
sense you know I'm not really sure if he
would have chosen one of those if he had
more time but Knight to e2 is the move
rook to c8 makes a lot of sense bringing
your roof's to do those open files Queen
back to b1 so definitely gonna try some
sort of exchange or something crazy
because right now magnus carlsen is kind
of backed up in this corner right here
Queen to e7 now decides to go ahead and
exchange off pieces right there
and then Knight to d4 and this is
actually a great outpost for Magnus
Carlsen this pawn here on e3 is really
tough for black to do anything with so
he can just kind of hang out here in the
center of the board which is where you
want your knight to hang out the knight
in the center just has more options on
board to move and so he's kind of gonna
control the center of the board black
doesn't have any pawns that he can move
to kind of force this to move so this is
a great great square for Magnus Carlsen
black now plays Knight to e4 does have
his own outpost here Queen to be to pawn
to f5 starting to counter-attack
on the Kings side rook over here to see
one important move to counter-attack
this long file that black is kind of
controlling and then a pivotal move in
the game onsen decides to play pawn to
f4 and the single thing is just a little
bit off the pawn taking here on f4 is
gonna be uncontested the Queen can't
take the Knights because the Queen's
protecting it can't really take the pawn
because Knight to e6 is just really
really awkward forking the rook and the
Queen doesn't want to take with his rook
because the rook can just swing up here
to c8 and capture but if we look at this
he could have chosen a different line
instead of pawn to f4 he could have
first taken with his rook here on a c1
magnus carlsen if he decided to take
with his queen let's say that would
protect the square here on f4 but then
after pawn to f4 then it gets awkward
cuz the pawn can't take here cuz then
the Queen would just capture here on d4
so you know why it's kind of stuck in
this this weird situation if instead he
takes with his rook you know still kind
of stands pawn to f4 he can now take
with this pawn you know because this
knight still being protected but then
the rook can just swing down here on f4
because it's now being unprotected by
the Queen here that would have been on
c1 so it definitely would have been a
lot better if he decided to go ahead and
take first on c1 unfortunately in in the
game decided to push forward with f4 it
just gave Magnus Carlsen a free pawn in
the game so the Queen has to come back
here to f6 and then we see pawn here to
g3 solidifying the pawn chain over on
the Kings side pushing forward with h4
as well again onsens just really trying
to find some sort of counter play
recognizing he's down in material magnus
carlsen it's very good when it comes
down to the in game and so he's just
kind of trying to force something right
here rook to d1 protecting this night
here on d4 wants to make sure you can
activate his queen doesn't want his most
important piece on board try and tie
down to this defense here on d4 so rook
to d1 very very good move rook to C
eighths magnus carlsen has no problem
exchanging off material on board Queen
to e2 rook down here to c3 and again
this is just kind of a last-ditch effort
from wanting to try to steal the game
away all Magnus Carlsen has to do is
just play correctly so Queen taking here
on h5 again in a long match a black
wouldn't just be sacrificing all
material just to try to get a quick one
but recognizing that at this point in
the game both sides have about 25
seconds I think we're on the clock it at
this point for even Magnus Carlsen so he
recognizes the Magnus Carlsen can easily
slip up at any given time and
kind of steal this game from it now the
night takes here on g3 we do see the
take and the roof takes here on g3 and
this is probably the next pivotal point
into the game Magnus Carlsen definitely
has to make sure he plays correctly if
there's just one misstep if he just
plays King to H one all of a sudden
things might start looking pretty bad
for him Queen to f4
all of a sudden onsen is really
threatening made right here we could see
Queen take here on d5 check but then
there's no way for white to continue
with his attack he may have to come down
here bring his knight to f3 trying to
stave off the attack but then you know
the black just has too many active
pieces on board he could eventually try
for a perpetual check or actually just
go for the jugular and try to actually
get a win here so after the pieces come
off the board both sides would probably
have about 10 seconds left it'd be very
very rapid for both sides to try to
advance one of their pawns but no one
has a clear-cut advantage in this
particular situation now if we come back
on board Magnus Carlsen doesn't really
make a lot of mistakes because he's just
too good at chess plays King 2f - you
want to centralize your King as much as
possible make it in an attacker start to
control some of the squares and that's
exactly what he does the Queen does come
here to f4 check but then Knight to f3
this stops pretty much all the attacks
that black had there's no good way for
him to continue he does try rook to h3
so that maybe he could play rook to h2
then you know the knight can't move
because it's being pinned down by this
Queen right here but then Magnus Carlsen
just starts going to work Queen to d5
forcing the King to come over here Queen
to h4 and then this particular spots
black resigns Magnus Carlsen not only
just had to get a draw but actually wins
in the last match to take the gold medal
in the and yes actually do give medals
outs to take the gold medal in the blitz
champion so we now have the world
champion of normal time chess of rapid
chess of 15 minutes and then now
it's chess which is the first time it's
happened definitely phenomenal that they
haven't always had that the the try
format of normal Blitzen rapid I'm sure
at one point of time someone else could
have done it but Magnus Carlsen
phenomenal showing from him I think in a
few years maybe some people some of the
young guns may challenge him in chess
but right now he's just he's just way
better than everyone in every single
format he is just better so you know his
opponents couldn't really do too much in
this situation it would have been
checkmate you know pretty soon he
could've brought his King back here
you know rook the eights it doesn't
really matter he can just force his
opponent to move capture the Queen you
know no no real good square so again his
opponent he was only down to a few
seconds anyway just decided to go ahead
and resign so a great match for Magnus
Carlsen 21 rounds of blitz can be pretty
exhausting because your mind just has to
go 100 miles an hour but he found so
many good moves and just dominated the
field so hopefully you guys enjoyed the
coverage of both the rapid and the blitz
championship congratulations to Magnus
Carlsen the world champion and pretty
much every format out there in chess
that matters that they did ask him about
bullet chest which is just one minute he
he said he doesn't think his his hands
would move fast enough but he definitely
thinks he could contend they also asked
him about you know the the format's
where all the pieces are are random you
know chess through 65 and he said he
would love to play that so be
interesting to watch him play a format
where you know a lot of the opening
theory is not memorized because that's
where I think he does very very well
although he he doesn't want all all
aspects of the chest so thanks for
watching and I'll see you guys in the
next video series